and Lily is John is a juggernaut do you  know him no John such a trip I mean some  people are just yeah this guy is there's  no Lenny home this guy cannot be left  alone at home and he's like me what a  trip and such you know an amazing  arrogance an amazing conviction of your  own that you've got it all figured yeah  a relentless carrot he told me once we  were  to understanding something and he said  nature loves you  ruthlessly  that's an interesting observation  ruthlessly Angeline was he speaking  specifically about you yeah well he and  I were the only thing people present it  was just a private conversation he used  to have this obi-wan kenobe robe 50 war  around esselman that was just hilarious  and he would just show up out of the fog  you know to lay these raps on you know  you know they didn't make too many of  John